genius playing listeners this podcast is
brought to you by betterhelp mental
health is mental wealth if you're
working on your physical health you
should be working on your mental health
as well it is important for you and you
carry this with you for the rest of your
life if you need somebody to talk to if
you are concerned that you're not going
where you need to be this is where
better help can help you sometimes we're
faced with the crossroads in life and we
don't know which path to take whatever
it is therapy can help you map out your
future and trust yourself to find the
way forward if you're thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com genius today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com genius he came and
then he started acting all innocent and
like I had no idea for what the reason
for this to be angry yeah he was like
this is Airbnb told me to call the
police and uh Nick he he assaulted me he
pushed me down the stairs and uh he
called me all these homophobic slurs in
five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast today we have a
very special guest we have freesia Park
once again she's been on here multiple
times obviously she's doing her YouTube
thing she has her own thing going on
dark hair very beautiful I love the
[__] hair you look amazing today
thank you cheers you piece of [__]
cheers to that yes I actually just cut
it like a couple days ago it looks great
this is the darkest I've seen her hair
in a very long time I was over it I was
looking too much like an ABG so I had to
get back to my roots want me to go so
dark just because you just I was just
over the highlights I just I needed a
change and it was it just didn't feel
like me anymore you know every girl
tells me this that when they go through
some [__] they have to either cut their
hair color or do something so that's the
thing I'm doing breakup Behavior even
though I'm still in my very loving
long-term relationship I'm just going
something wrong that was wrong I think
there's a lot of internal turmoil that
I'm going through but like that's
probably being reflected outside with my
haircut is a lot more healthier than
what guys do like guys will [__]
break [__] get angry get violent girls
will just [__] change their makeup
color their hair and I see it happen
every time either it's break up
something stresses them out their
workplace the next thing you know I see
new here I'm like what's going on like
what's happening
I have to shed this former shell of
myself I hate this yeah no honestly when
I like chop off all of my hair it just
makes me feel like I'm getting a like a
new start to life yeah it's like you're
you're topping off all those years in
the baggage and like the [__] that you
don't want to hold on to it's all gone
yeah like they'll do like I understand
the uh the Pamper day so for example um
uh tears and Tim's like nanny is gone
right and I'm really close to Tim and
chia
and so we talked about this where they
had to leave him recently she had a
massage set up and you know she's a
stay-at-home mom and she's taking care
of two a toddler and a brand new newborn
she hasn't knees that day and then Tim
was like hey can you come in and help
with us of course she comes back her
mood's great you just need that [__]
reset sometimes and I know how important
that is because I need that [__] so for
her she's like hey can you help I'm like
got you I'm over there go get your
[__] massage come back and then she
gets her hour massage coming back her
mood's perfect and then she could be a
better Mom especially as because like
like you're not living for yourself for
those
of those very formative years too it's
like all about raising these babies so I
didn't really understand this [__]
either
um where um Mariel had a friend who was
talking to me about the stuff and I
didn't [__] get what she was saying
where she was like
she just had a kid and this was years
ago and she was explaining to us like I
kind of lost my identity like when I had
these kids I'm like what are you talking
about like you should love your kids put
your love into your kids she goes that's
not what I'm saying it's like when I go
out and I meet people and I talk to them
I'm no longer let's say her name is
Christine I'm no longer Christine I am
Sarah's mom and I didn't understand it's
like well you should be proud of that
and this is me and my I didn't say this
to her but in my head I just didn't
[__] get it and it's like oh from
here on out you're never your your
individuality if it was something that
was important to you starts to disappear
because you are now identified as this
child's mother and I only clicked in me
like maybe a couple years ago I see what
she's talking about like all your wants
and your needs are very important but
then for you because you want to be a
good mother or a parent you [__] push
that [__] out you know this is what it's
like this is the kid and then these
moments where you don't have time for
yourself you find to lose your sense of
self and then you feel you get a little
depressed yeah you get a little sad even
even though you love your kids but it's
like yo I was a person before this you
know what I mean and I I get it now I
think you have to be prepared to lose
some of yourself if I think that's a big
indicator of whether or not you're ready
for motherhood and whenever people ask
me like oh if you got pregnant today
would you keep it and I I would say yes
right now but at the same time I'm a
little hesitant to say yes because I
know that
that would mean I would have to abandon
like my entire life and I'm not ready to
do that yet so therefore I'm not ready
to be a mother yet is kind of how I look
at it it's a it's a new chapter that
I've seen it brings a different type of
Joy but there's a reason why people are
like well I I need some like I said I
understand when the parents they they go
home
and they look at their kid and they go
I'm gonna stay in the car for another
hour yeah you know chill for a [__]
second because it's everything's about
them and it's not a problem it's just
that sometimes you kind of miss these
moments where you had for yourself and
even then like now I feel that because I
have the business I have everything else
and there's moments where I'm just like
damn I missed this listen I'm not saying
I miss covet all right but during the
time when covert was popping I had a lot
of me time yeah I was walking just
aimlessly for 12 miles just in my own
thoughts doing what the [__] ever I
wanted and then now that that kind of
disappeared I kind of missed that a
little bit it's like oh I miss when I
could just like decompress whatever the
[__] I want so I completely understand
like so when you know when girls do
their whole thing I see the makeup
change it's a couple of things I see
I know when somebody goes through a
breakup like like a Homeworld when I see
them posting all these stories about how
amazing their life is it's like you know
what for the first time in a long time
I'm here reading a book
no that was me after my last breakup I
would post like mere selfies of me at my
yoga studio like oh like yo self-care is
freaking amazing
because you need that pep talk cause you
just went through some [__] hard [__]
but I always see that [__] it's like
with the girls who needs men I think you
guys are that [__] you know a [__]
town he isn't doing [__] I'm like when
did you get dumped what happened I'm
like this [__] [__] cheated on me
and I'm like I could see it because
suddenly they were in such a long
relationship that they put all their
time into each other and they didn't put
that time into themselves so now they're
back in the gym working out again
um their self-confidence is getting a
little bit better because they're
reinvesting to themselves because you
get really comfortable in a relationship
you don't care about your haircut you
don't care about the way you look you
don't care about none of that and I
think for me too I've been in such a
long relationship with Mario sometimes I
forget like and maybe you shouldn't wear
something else besides basketball shorts
yeah because you I see her she puts in
like even for her she's starting to
realize that too where she's just
wearing the same frumpy shirt yeah the
same [__] and then she started her
self-confidence goes a little lower yeah
it's like well I should learn how to put
on [__] makeup again and it's
practice Yeah that's actually like kind
of what I've been going through a little
bit in my relationship
we or at least I'll speak for myself
like I got like so comfortable I would
just be at home no makeup like sitting
on the couch with my leg up the most
unattractive positions like
he farted and [__]
um
but I don't fart in front of my
boyfriend still remember we had this
conversation
I did by accident
I was like [__] because
slam the door oh God
um but now I'm kind of going back
because I you know me like I was someone
who cared a lot about my presentation
and I would put a lot of effort into my
makeup that was something I really
enjoyed and fashion and buying new
clothes was like a part of like who I
was but I lost a lot of that and I would
blame it on my boyfriend a lot being
like you know I don't know because I'm
with you you know I'm just comfortable
but it's more more about me and that's
kind of what I've been learning and
maneuvering through lately so I've been
trying more yeah but more for myself
like it's not really for him anymore
it's more about me reclaiming like who I
was and what brought me joy like before
I met him too because I I definitely
lost some of that but
yeah it's interesting like I when I see
people who put themselves together like
for me I like my original trade is just
comedy I'm just supposed to be [__]
funny right and you don't ever think
about
the last thing on my list is what I look
like it's something I could care less
and I've told you multiple times
sometimes Mario's like you why don't you
ever look at a [__] mirror before you
leave the house right I just do not care
because my thing is I'm just trying to
be a funny guy and just happy all the
time like I'm looking for Joy but then
the thing is too it's like
I don't know why I don't know if people
ever think about this because as I get
older I'm in my mid-30s right now I'm
like 35. I'm like there's gonna be a
time where even the thought of like
getting dressed up is literally the last
thing on your list so it's like while
you're younger and you have these
moments to yourself and uh at least up
until my 50s I I want to take time to
even care a little bit about how I look
because I'm gonna look back at these
photos and I'm like dude the [__] is
this like what are you doing and then I
just I don't know why but like recently
I'm like okay let's let's take some time
to think about how you present yourself
and when you go out like maybe give a
[__] a little bit more and it does set
your mood for the day it really does
like when I go out like when I get a
haircut like the past like I say six or
seven months because things have been so
hectic with the store in Hawaii which by
the way people in Maui you guys are
going through some [__] right now we'll
we'll put I'll talk about it later but
like that whole moment where it was just
everything was going into like not my
personal self-development that makes me
happy it was just kind of like you just
put on the Wayside and you get used to
it it becomes your normal every [__]
day like even
I don't know like doing your hair it's
like why but it's like you should do it
yeah like why the [__] not it'll make
you feel better and it kind of like
affects what you do for the rest of the
rest of the day yeah even I find myself
when I do get ready even if I have
nowhere to go it makes me want to go out
and be productive and do [__] too like
versus if I'm at home just lounging in a
T-shirt
I just want to stay home and Lounge you
know like I feel like just dressing up
no matter what your day looks like helps
you or at least me become more
productive too
and also too like I was watching this
random like Jordan uh Peterson clip he
[__] pops up on my [__] so much and I
don't understand why like it just pops
up all the time so Jordan Peterson he's
like a clinical psychologist he gets a
lot of heat because of um
he's very just like black and white
about a lot of things
um and look I I understand I like some
of the stuff he says and there's some
things that I disagree with and he he
talked about this concept of
he was breaking down in a the way a
clinical psychologist would break down
like the usage of what makeup is right
so he was having this conversation he
was well why do women wear makeup and
it's like because they want to attract
the opposite sex and somebody was trying
to explain to them like okay
yeah that's true a hundred percent like
the basis and the foundation of why
people get ready is to look attractive
to other people but I feel like as
people we've also have kind of evolved
from that to the point where now it
becomes like this
a good thing to do for ourselves there
is truth in what he says right like when
you put on makeup like he was breaking
it down to the science of when you wear
red lipstick it's a sign of arousal like
when you blush I get it like I don't
think I'm denying that fact I completely
understand but it's not as black and
white as it is a hundred percent people
definitely do dress up and look good
because they do enjoy when somebody
compliments them right because it
reflects how they feel about themselves
so like the idea that makeup is done for
yourself sometimes it's hard for people
to understand but I I do get it like I
remember working at my parents store and
it would be like girls who would come in
and they're coming in for for a
hairpiece right they would come into the
store and they would treat me like [__]
their [__] is [__] up and they're like
what the [__] is your [__] why are you
looking at me like that just [__]
going off on me and then the next day
they would come and their hair's done
hey baby how are you oh my god oh [__]
it was just because you look like [__]
so you felt like [__] yeah and their
mood was directly correlated to what
they look like and how they felt I mean
I get it it makes sense to me you know
yeah makes sense you know so what I
wanted to talk about today
was and if people really enjoyed this
podcast topic that um I had with um
Muriel about traveling so a lot of
people when they travel
there's a lot of anxiety that goes with
it and I completely understand because
I'm a very anxious person and so
sometimes people want to prep so much so
nothing can go wrong when they travel
the problem with that is that you cannot
prep for that things bad things will
happen you're in a foreign country you
don't know the language you don't know
what's going on and that's the chaos
that you absolutely have to accept so
like
I was watching this girl's stories and
the
you know it's like anything bad that
can't happen will happen and that was
your situation and I was watching just
your stories and I was getting pissed I
was getting heated because I'm like how
the [__] is this even possible so you
went to uh you were going all over the
place this was like the trip of a
lifetime it was almost like you were
going to get the electric chair the next
day type of trip
this [__] is [__] everywhere this
looks amazing yeah so where did you go
so it was actually my very first time in
Europe and a group of my friends that I
mean the group changed with every city
but uh we went to London first and then
made our way to Crete which is an island
in Greece and I have this beautiful over
there it's the beaches are
and then after Greece went to Paris nice
how was Paris
or something okay so the thing about
Paris is
a I feel like I didn't like have enough
time there to really get a good you know
feel for it I don't like to categorize
something as like this place
I feel like I just like didn't have
enough time with it with the right
people either because it was like a
large group and you can't really get a
lot done when you're traveling with a
big group of friends oh uh specifically
like in Paris yeah things are so small
yeah yeah yeah and so
one thing I will say about European
cities is that they remind me of New
York so much that I don't care
okay so like nothing really nothing
phases me in like London and Paris like
it's cool for a sec when you see all the
buildings and stuff but every like other
corner I was like oh that reminds me of
New York and this reminds me of New York
but I will say that like Paris I wish
that I could have spent more time just
like with a friend who maybe lives there
I feel like you need a local guide so
100 so we went to Paris right uh Mariel
has a few friends that live in France
and you know they kind of say stuff that
everybody says who lives in an area
where everybody visits they're like yeah
you kind of do have to know a local
because there's so many tourist traps
there and this it's there's so many
tourists you know what I mean so like
yeah you're going to go to I mean by the
way like I'm not making a general life
I'm not saying that Paris is trash at
all like they're [__] beautiful
places in Europe and because they have
such a long history and it's been around
there for so long you see like an
intermingling of Art and religion and
even when you see like religion then you
see these old churches like it's
beautiful like I'm trying to figure out
how the [__] did somebody build this
like thousands of years ago
it's amazing but when we went there we
had a terrible experience with a lot of
food because everything was based off a
TripAdvisor and none of these locals go
there at all so when we got
recommendations from Mariel's friends
places were dope right and then we met
some of our other friends too and she
goes yeah you Paris is good for a couple
days but you got to go to like the south
of France all these other places but
we're not going to know these things
because we're only going to the spots
that we see on Tick Tock and Instagram
and these people don't know [__] either
you know yeah so I I will say also like
Paris I feel like is a place where you
need to know like the ins and outs of
yeah like there's so much more I feel
like that you can do Beyond like the
Eiffel Tower and museums like I feel
like you need to explore like the
underground music scene and like the
Arts and we don't know you know yeah so
I do want to go back to Paris eventually
but
based on my experience in Paris so far
it's not my favorite and look when
you're a tourist out there like you
stick out like a [__] sore thumb yeah
so like specifically if you're next to
the Eiffel Tower somebody's always gonna
try to Jack you they're trying to
[__] sell you some [__] they're
trying to put like these red bands on
your wrist so they could force you to
pay money and like I had that happen to
a couple of my friends when we were
there I just look like a mean person so
people generally don't come up to me and
I'm not a small guy either but my
friends who are smaller Asian people
immediately they're harassing them
they're trying to put this [__] on their
wrist they're like oh you got to pay for
that that's just like 50 bucks you got
to pay for it are you stealing from me
like [__] like that happened
um my buddy Bart has a story too where
they did some type of similar [__]
to him and it was like late at night and
he was around like the Eiffel Tower or
something you wanted to do like a night
jog or just walk around and dudes like
ganged up on him and try to force him to
pay for something and Bart literally
just got butt naked and started
threatening them and they're like this
guy's a [__] Maniac yeah you gotta
I'm crazy
jumped by like six guys yeah and then
Bart it's just psychopath he was like
let's [__] go and they're like okay
this guy's [__] nuts but you know
every place has like a weird thing that
happens like I said if you don't know
the ins and outs it's just really hard
to navigate especially Paris is so
compacted it's like when you go to New
York and you don't know anybody there
it's also difficult in New York yeah you
know but then like because I know so
many people who live there they take me
to spots they show me the places and I'm
like this is so much more fun compared
to other people who went there and
they're like it's kind of whack out here
I was like you got to know somebody you
know what I'm saying so after you went
so the first place you stopped was where
London how's London London honestly it
again reminded me so much of New York
I definitely experienced a little more
racism in London so I I was surprised
but I shouldn't have been surprised
because it's like I get it everyone's
like just English out there
um but the food was amazing there's a
lot of like pop and chefs that are out
there it was amazing like so memorable
and I'm usually like very hard to
impress with food at least but like that
everything we ate in London was just so
so so good they have a lot of Southeast
Asian [__] going on a lot of Indian food
going on here's the thing
um My Buddy Joe his wife is from the UK
I was like hey so what's like the best
food out like in the UK in London and
everything she says is everything but
like white people like produces like
British food or whatever she goes we
have amazing food but it's just not our
food yeah she's like dude our Middle
Eastern food our Indian food is some of
the best that you'll ever eat yeah I was
like but what about like British food
she goes well let's not talk about that
not the other [__] it's [__] fire
there was a pretty
um mid-tier to upscale restaurant that
we went to called fallow amazing but
that was like kind of English Modern
English but it was everything was just
amazing so that was good I think any
city that you go to that's Metropolitan
that has money you're gonna find some
amazing restaurants because where
there's money A lot of people are going
to open up their the dining places out
there because they have high foot
traffic and it's competitive any place
that is competitive out there will have
really good food like there was a clip
recently
that I this is a little bit different
but kind of on topic
if you guys know a guy named Ben Baller
he's like you know the streets Jeweler
is what he calls himself but he put out
this clip that was literally the dumbest
[__] I've ever heard in my [__] life
and he was on the coffee hour with
um Graham Norton and he said that La
Korean food is infinitely better than
anything out in Korea and everybody was
like what the [__] are you talking about
and I think that the part that irritated
me about that was like number one I
understand Ben baller's perspective
because he is
an old ass Korean dude old ass Korean
dudes kind of see Korea and he grew up
in Cape Town so he has a lot of K-Town
Pride
but if he's been to Korea in the recent
years there's absolutely no way he would
say that like it's almost laughable like
his opinion is opinions are subjective
but that statement to me is almost
objectively wrong like it's hard to say
that I know what bothers you about this
because it bothers me this is what I
realized I learned this about myself
recently and you and I are oddly similar
but in the worst way is possible
um but I hate it when people speak in
absolutes when they haven't expanded
outside of what they already know so
like when they're just like this is fact
this is true and nothing else matters
when they haven't explored outside of
their outdated opinions like then that
[__] is annoying yeah and I say that too
because when I was younger I used to be
like that yeah I would I would I was an
absolutist like no [__] way yeah
absolutely not yeah now what I say is
like I see that because there's so much
things that you could pick and take from
somebody right so for somebody like that
like obviously Ben Baller he's the older
he's you know listen Ben if we ever meet
in person I understand like don't be
offended by this you're Dusty like
that's a dusty ass opinion you know what
I'm saying and he says he's an
absolutist he says everything in [__]
absolutes and a lot of old guys do this
[__] yeah and I [__] hate it it gets
under my skin because it means that
you're not open to somebody else's
opinion and thoughts and you only think
that way and you should see the comments
right and the comments were kind of
light and obviously I posted on my
stories and all my followers who went to
Korea and are Korean are like there is
no way that you went to Korea ate the
food there and you think that I'm
talking about you go to the XI jongs
like the marketplaces those foods that
people have done for years and they're
only making one [__] dish you're
saying that the Korean restaurants in
K-Town that serve multiple they're gonna
outbeat this impossible and for just to
get perspective to people he's probably
thinking about this and this is to Ben
baller's credit there were times when I
was younger like before to Korea we
would have to bring vitamins all these
different snacks and whatever because
they were getting everything from like
China and they didn't know about the
quality control there so they would ask
us to bring stuff for them it's not like
that anymore Korea has all the stuff we
have and more and people would even say
this the beef in America are somewhere
not true
Hano like Korean beef is so [__] good
you don't even know right it's so
delicious I'm talking about there are
foods in Korea that I still like
salivate over just thinking about you go
to a Korean restaurant in Korea in Korea
in laket town they put out panchan which
are side dishes
it's just there like you just eat it
with the food or whatever when you go to
a Korean restaurant that's decent they
put the same amount of attention and
Care into their panchan that they do to
the main dish to the point where you
don't even realize that oh there's still
food coming out
that's how good it is it is so
Metropolitan and competitive in Korea
with the cuisine that they grew up in
that they're born with that they've done
new and better things that La is so
behind on that is how good Korean food
is in Korea so when he said that I'm
like how can you speak in this absolute
have you been there do you have a tongue
do you just eat ass all day we did what
I'm saying I just never it was it got
under my skin in in the weirdest way
possible I don't know yeah
I love Korea like I when I went there I
was mind blown how good the food was
yeah like to the point where I'm like
how the [__] is it that every meal that
I'm eating is amazing this is weird it's
yeah it's so good and he said and he
goes in Cape Town when you go to Korea
like any Korean restaurant you go is
amazing that is that's not true
so true absolutely not true there are so
many Korean restaurants I went to where
like ah this shit's like not good yeah
you know what I mean it's like I can
make this way better at home yeah and
people still till this day since I moved
to LA like not too long ago it's been
two years or a little over two years
actually uh people are always like oh
it's Ellie K Town like food better than
New York's K-Town food and it's like yes
I know like New York has been
progressing so much which by the way
there's also flushing there's also Fort
Lee in Jersey like the Korean food there
has always been fire so I hate when
people like pin me to like basically
give in to like this really K-Town food
is so much better
which I don't agree with that anymore
because like today I feel like L.A K
Town has just like
stayed consistent and the same but they
haven't evolved yeah like I I definitely
and you know people might disagree with
that but like I'll give you a great
example right there's a small town in
Jersey that has only Korean food there's
like a Korean town area right dog their
Korean food was hella good it's so good
that was tripping I was like I went to a
Sunday cook place right so for people
who don't know what that is our blood
sausage it's filled with rice it does
lots of herb spices and noodles or
whatever
and there's a lot of places that does
think they're really bad there's assume
that I went to it was better than the
stuff that I had in Cape Town it was in
Jersey I was jerseys Korean food is fire
and that's blasphemous for me to say as
a New Yorker I'll be canceled by my
fellow New Yorkers for saying them but
Jersey's like Korean food is fire yeah
my cousin will like you know he knows I
live in L.A and he was like I don't base
it off of La food stuff like it's not
gonna be that good and I ate I was like
you're tripping this [__] is hella good
yeah because he was like a little
self-conscious about that stuff because
he was concerned that I was gonna be
like uh I don't want Korean food here
why would I get Korean food here when I
could get it in LA and I'm talking about
yo Jersey you should be proud of that
area because it's Korean as [__] and the
food is [__] delicious and then we
also have uh and then a prudak
restaurant in Jersey that's really
popular [__] amazing like I I and I
don't even like spicy food like that and
I was devouring that [__] it's like the
food experience everywhere can be
amazing so when people speak about
absolutes about food it's a little weird
for me you know what were you talking
about before then London yeah London
food was great yeah Greece food was hit
or miss it was good they're cucumbers
tomatoes and cheese were like on another
level and olive oil like it's it's so
good there it tastes different that's
what everybody says it's like so good
like you go to like Italy Greece for
Rome like the olive oil that you eat it
it's like there's it's nuanced like it's
fruity it's bright yeah it's deep you
know for me when I get olive oil here I
don't know if I haven't eaten enough but
you know I bought like an expensive
bottle here and there I'm just gonna get
this cheaper one because it kind of
tastes the same to me yeah yeah so like
um like when I when I saw you travel and
I see you go like it makes me happy when
I see people travel because for me it
was
one of the things that opened up my mind
to a lot of how other people live and
think you know and I see stuff online
where people who have never traveled in
their life they have an opinion about
how other people live and they kind of
stay in this closed area and it's a lot
of Americans who do that who don't
[__] travel they they judge from
their from their [__] couch and
so when I when I see people who travel
it's still because now you're opening
your mind to other things and
specifically for someone like you and me
who love food it gives us another
perspective it's like oh I want to go
back home and try something
my lovely genius brain listeners are you
stressed are you tired do you just need
somebody to talk to you so you can get
the Wiggles out well that's where better
help comes genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends my friends I have been
talking about mental health and how
important it is in your life and guess
what it should be important in your life
as well and better help can be there for
you my friends sometimes we're faced
with a crossroad in life and we don't
know which path to take maybe you're
thinking about a career change or
feeling like your relationship needs
some TLC whatever it is therapy can help
you map out your future and trust
yourself to find the way forward my
friends better help has been helping me
for quite a while and I freaking love it
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help but try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched with the licensed therapist
and switch therapist anytime for no
additional charge let therapy be your
map with better help visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-eop.com genius
you know what I mean and it's so dope
like for example like that olive oil
thing I always hear people talk about
olive oil and like the simple
ingredients in other countries because
people have an issue of sometimes other
countries because they call them very
xenophobic right they go well they only
care about their people most countries
are like that yeah right like they
protect what is important to them and
their culture which is what makes it
dope for us to travel to because imagine
if we went to another country and it was
the same experience that we had here
then what the [__] is the point there is
absolutely like I'm not saying
xenophobia is good but I'm saying that
sometimes people are confusing
xenophobia for people who like the
customs and countries the way that it is
because it's what they know and what
they love right and so like Japan for
example they call it Japan very
xenophobic and I actually do agree I've
been there and
um even people who live in Japan will
agree and maybe they'll you know expand
on this in the comments or Japan people
you can go and live there as long as you
want right but if you are not Japanese
you're not Japanese right they're kind
to you they're polite to you they treat
you with kindness and for a majority of
time there's obviously bad experiences
everywhere but if you're not Japanese
Japanese yeah and that's their
preservation of their culture so
sometimes when Outsiders come in they'll
do things that are just
abrupt and obtrusive you know and they
do not like that they have a flow like
there's a video that you'll see online
that you guys can look up it's like a
top-down video of a Japanese subway
system and even though it looks like
chaos everybody is walking the way that
they should the Japan just for my when
I'm in Japan I feel like I'm in a school
fish you just have to belong and move
yeah
like even in the Subways I me and my
boyfriend were in the Subways during
rush hour and we're like you just gotta
like stand your ground and move with the
people that are pushing you into the
Subways because like this is just how it
is oh you just have to like [__] fit
in a hundred percent yeah what did you
think about the uh the fashion in like
London and everything else were people
pretty fashionable or pretty relaxed
London I didn't see a lot of good
fashion uh but I might not have been in
the right places but generally speaking
it I didn't care for it Paris was
slightly
better in terms of fashion Greece I mean
everybody was just like in Beachwear so
it didn't matter yeah
um but yeah I I feel like if I explored
certain neighborhoods of London I would
have seen more but I thought like what I
think what I noticed differently and I
wonder if people can agree with this is
like
Japanese people in terms of where you're
at they seem a little more relaxed with
fashion there's a lot of people who look
great and and dress really dope but
outwardly as long as they're just like
clean but they're like working and stuff
they're not really worried about the
hottest dope as [__] like you see some
people who are just wearing regular
t-shirts and whatever and then you see
somebody who looks nice Korea on the
other hand when I was there I was like
everybody looks nice like what is going
on here like I I when I went to create
Mario prep me for that she goes you
can't wear what you're wearing in Korea
you will stick out so much you can't
just wear a basketball short and a
t-shirt I'm like why not she goes
because nobody does that like you'll
look like a piece of [__] and I remember
when I was in the airport I'm like these
people are on 14 hour flights and their
makeup
I mean I prefer Japanese fashion a lot
more it's more about like minimalism and
everything is like good quality clean
lines like simple which is why we you
know secret society is very fashion
Basics and so like when I went there I
was wearing all secret society stuff
um and people liked what I was wearing
like I remember when I went there I went
to this one tonkatsu spot and then Mary
was translating what he was saying what
are you saying he was like he's saying
he dressed like a cool guy
but it's like because it fits in with
their aesthetic so it kind of makes
sense but like in Korea now they're a
lot better with like individualism
because I saw people wearing different
styles or whatever but it's different
styles in the sense of this style a lot
of people wear this style a lot of
people yeah yeah yeah before when I went
there or I went to Japan it was like
when olive green drab was in everybody
was an olive green trap I was like holy
[__] there is no variation here but I
think because things are becoming so
Global now like in Korea like people are
dressing like when I went there recently
well last year a lot of young kids were
dressed up like grease lightning [__]
high-waisted jeans like thick denim
plain black T-shirt rolled up sleeve
cigarette box right oh interesting it
was [__] fascinating I'm like oh
that's just kind of I can't pull it off
but they imagine you're not wearing that
could never no I I would just look like
a mechanic
with your ass cracking you know I'm like
I I can't do what you do but I'm like
that's very cool and they were wearing
like the the chain around the necklace
and stuff I'm like oh this must be like
a hot thing that they're doing because I
saw it multiple specifically in hongdae
where all the young college kids are at
and I was like oh the fashion year is
pretty interesting but I didn't see
anybody dress like in basketball shorts
and a t-shirt yeah [__] talking ever
everybody had their BB cream on some
people had like the the the the heel
[__] where they're a little taller and
I'm like oh you gotta look your best out
here because they're very concerned
about what other people are going to say
about that yeah that's the one thing
about Korean culture that like I really
don't like is how it's so appearance
focused and like if you go see your
mom's friend or like if I go if my mom's
friends like see me for the first time
it's always a comment about like my
weight how I look my hair it's always an
appearance thing which I really despise
but that's that's the culture it is what
it is yeah and like I think I'm very
blessed to be in a blessed and sometimes
very hard but my mom's a hillbilly you
know so she doesn't give a [__] she's
like just be happy and just you know be
comfortable just don't be dirty you know
so I didn't realize what it was really
like to be in a traditional traditional
Korean family until I came to K-Town in
LA and I saw these stories and what
other people I saw it growing up in
other people's saying I just didn't pay
attention to it but I didn't realize how
prevalent it was in other people's
families right yeah my mom makes weight
stuff or whatever whatnot but it wasn't
to the extreme like so one of the things
that Meryl was shocked at was
uh mother-in-law is called show money
right so like typically
I'm speaking in generalities I've
created the Korean American Experience
I'm not sure what it's like in Korea but
when you go to your mother-in-law's
house you're supposed to be the ex the
example of what it is to be a good
housewife
you're cleaning the dishes you're
cleaning up the table you're helping
cook you're doing all the stuff you're
asking you're shielding what she needs
and what she wants my mom hates that
[__] so when Mario came she was prep she
goes and her mom was telling hey make
sure that you represent our you know our
family and ourselves really nicely I'm
saying I was like I'll do the dishes
Mama's like the [__] out of here go sit
down what are you doing I go sit down go
watch TV she goes no I'll do it she goes
don't come in my kitchen like go sit
down and then my mom's like chopping up
like [__] fruits or whatever and Mary
was shocked she goes I love it here I
can't do something to do anything be
myself and so Mary was like in her
pajamas or whatever whatnot she's like
why are you dressed in this clothes like
go [__] relax go get in your pajamas
what are you doing and she's just
watching shows with my mom cracking up
and laughing and she goes I love it here
this is very different from what I
expected I'm like yeah my mom's
different like she's a piece of [__]
like she's a hillbilly so like I
understand like that perspective that
but I never got to experience it yeah
because
um I just didn't have a parents like
that so I understand it's very hard
why'd you gain so much weight like I
have a friend who she told me that she
was at a wedding
an aunt came up to her and was like you
know your mom's really skinny and thin
how come you're so fat
oh my god dude that [__] got my blood
boiling I was like who the [__] do you
think you are talking to somebody like
that and she was like yeah your mom's
skinny and fit like it doesn't make
sense that you're fat
I can't it's just so toxic I could you
imagine somebody speaking to you like
like an aunt that you don't even know
yeah
I would like flip my [__] [__] and
then she told me that her husband had to
step in and be like hey you can't talk
to my wife like that like this that's
inappropriate they're like no I just
wanna it'll benefit her it's like it
doesn't matter if you whatever the [__]
you think it's gonna benefit my wife you
cannot talk to my wife like that she was
crying she's like you know you're at
this [__] wedding and they go yeah
your mom's a lot prettier than you I
don't understand why you're so ugly it's
basically what they're saying
uh
[Music]
it's just so shocking like I'm like uh
okay yeah I'll stab you you know [__]
oh so anyways we're going back to this
topic like she was going explain to me
what the [__] happened and it was in
Paris right oh yeah
okay so when they warn you about things
you know like this is you know the I've
had Airbnb horror stories in Paris watch
out but like when people tell you these
things you're like it's not gonna happen
to me
but the worst case scenario literally
happened to me and my friends so
we get to Paris we're tired from Greece
we're chucking into our Airbnb
immediately it's like not what we expect
because we had to climb seven flights of
stairs everything is a walk-up pretty
much in Paris I guess
but it was never like explained to us
that this would be like a seven-story
walk-up in darkness there's no light
anywhere too and we all had our luggage
so we're like oh my God same experience
whatever this is a Parisian thing it's
fine we'll get in everything will be
fine
we got into the Airbnb and at first I'm
like oh this is really cute it looks
like the photos but for some reason it
feels a little cramped cramped like the
ceilings are super low it's the same
experience smaller than like five five
you're gonna have to duck your head and
like things just seemed really outdated
and that's fine again like I'm from New
York I get the tiny shitty apartment
experience I understand that so I was
still like okay this is we're in Paris
this is what you get whatever
um so everybody's checking in and like
checking out the place and
everyone has like a problem with it like
something is off like the the juju and
the air was just like not it
um and then we were just like
trying to wash our hands at this point
there wasn't any soap like all the ASAP
bottles were just like used and empty so
I was like huh that's weird like they
should have given us at least soap like
Essentials are part of the package why
don't we have soap anywhere in the
kitchen in the bathroom so I was like
okay I'm definitely gonna like message
the host about that because we need
[__] soap yeah
at the very least so I'm also the type I
lived with a lawyer so I learned a lot
of
um like behaviors from him and I
document everything in my life here
everything so I just started taking
videos and pictures of the soap of the
empty bottles because even in the
drawers it was like a stash of empty
ASAP bottles so like why wouldn't you
just like throw this out like I don't
understand why he's keeping all this
garbage in here but it's all like grimy
and gross so then I was like okay taking
videos and photos at this point not
knowing that I would eventually use them
um and then like everything in the walls
and stuff were like like all this paint
and stuff were like concaving and like
breaking off and we booked this place
because they advertise it as having
Central AC yeah there was no Central AC
this is an old ass building all he had
in the in the apartment where like these
fans like the old school fans so we're
like
dude like if we knew that this was the
situation we would have booked somewhere
else because it's hot it's it's summer
in Paris like it's like monkey it's
muggy it's humid it's disgusting
so that was another thing I started
documenting I go into the bathroom and
like
there's just like black mold all over
the tiles that is the one thing I cannot
get down with is like a grimy shower
yeah if it feels like a locker room
shower like I don't want to step float
in there like well yeah you're watching
this and you come out there's also an
Airbnb that's supposed to be like
spotless yeah like there's mold all over
the bathtub in the tiles like the drain
had like mind you I'm a clean freak but
like I'm also very flexible and I'm open
to like you know understanding what the
situation and the context is yeah when
you're traveling you have to be flexible
yeah but the the bathroom shower
situation nobody was down for like we
were just like this is nasty like do we
have to shower with flip-flops but I was
like no like you cannot this is like
where we draw the line and this is where
I become Karen it's like there was a
dead body in here I don't think I could
do this yeah so there's just so many
things not right but then I was like
whatever let me like just talk to the
host we'll figure it out we also had
plans for the day it was our first day
in Paris every minute counts because our
time is so short so we went out went to
the Louvre
um just saw the outside and then went to
like go get something to eat and while
this was all happening like I was just
going back and forth with Airbnb like
the host was like not responsive and not
really
not really addressing what I was asking
for and mind you like I am very
professional and respectful this entire
conversation because everything is a
paper trail also but you have to like
just be very quiet thousand percent so I
was just trying to find a solution and
he his response long story short was
just like oh it's not that hot this week
so it doesn't matter if there's no
Central AC but there are a bunch of fans
that you can use that's not no one has
ever like had a problem with this
um uh regarding the tiles and like the
mold in the bathroom
um this is completely sanitary because
like every before every guest comes we
completely clean the place the cleaners
come and whatever
um so it's sanitary is what he was
saying and he was just like oh and also
with the soap I have no problem going to
the store and bringing up soap but it
can't be until like later tonight so I
was like okay you're not like really
addressing anything yeah you basically
said like I'm I lied to you and you have
to accept it yeah so then I there is
also in the cancellation policy with
this listing in particular because it
varies per listing
this one said that you could cancel
on like even after you check in you can
cancel and get a partial refund so you
would just get refunded for the days
that you don't stay
um but I don't know why Airbnb sets it
up this way the host has to accept that
request though so I submitted that
request I was like listen we're willing
to pay for the first night even though
we have no intention of saying because
at this point we already didn't want to
stay like it was bad juju like
disgusting one of our friends one of our
guy friends had to sleep on the sofa
because it's like a sleeper and even the
sleeper was just like covered in stained
cigarette burns like like it was nasty
um so then we were just like yeah we
just don't feel comfortable staying here
we want to like just rebook with another
place
um because this is not what we expected
um I hope that's okay we're still
willing to pay for the first night even
though we're not gonna stay here no
matter what your answer is We're not
gonna stay here
um but we would like to get a refund for
their nights we're not staying and he
just rejected he was like happy to give
you a discount or whatever
um but yeah like none of our you can
read my reviews no one really had a
problem except for a few so I hope you
have a comfortable stay like and I was
like what the [__] he's not letting like
he's not letting us leave yeah
no that's one I was like things were
like building and we were all getting
angrier and angrier
so I was like okay talking to this guy
is not going to solve anything so I went
to Airbnb
um I was on the phone with them and they
basically the girl was basically on my
side the customer service agent and she
was like dude I'm so sorry that's a
shitty situation just document
everything and send it to me and you
will most like if everything you're
saying is true you're gonna get your
[__] back you're gonna get a full refund
um so I was like okay Bet great amazing
so I go back and like I send her all the
details she's not really responsive
either because uh I mean yeah yeah
that's fine
um
but the timing of how everything else is
about to play is just so bad we have
like a reservation that we're supposed
to go to
um within the 30 minutes that I sent all
the documents and evidence to Airbnb but
I'm not like getting any word so I can't
necessarily rebook a place yet because I
still it's not the other spot yeah yeah
like I'm still not sure like
everything's just up in the air
um this Airbnb host is also now
unresponsive so I don't know what the
situation is so I'm like whatever we'll
just go to dinner and it'll play out
it'll work itself out and we'll you know
whatever so then we got to dinner and on
the Uber to dinner
I got a message from Airbnb and an email
saying your reservation has been
canceled you've been refunded and full
and I'm like yes amazing but also like
what is going on now because all of our
stuff and luggage is in the Airbnb we're
on our way to dinner now which is like a
reservation that's really hard to get so
you can't necessarily like Let It Go so
we're like I was just like it'll be fine
right Airbnb said they would give us
next steps
so we'll just enjoy dinner
go back to the property which is only 15
minutes away
um get our stuff return the key back in
the mailbox and it'll be fine because
it's not like there are guests coming in
to check in or anything
but I guess Airbnb also sent an email to
Marcel the host that's his name [__] you
Marcel yeah [__]
um he gets the message I guess from
Airbnb saying that the reservation was
canceled and that we were refunded and
this is when he's like completely
unhinged he starts messaging me all like
hosta like where are you what are you
doing right now and I was like uh uh you
CA oh hell no yeah after he was like
trying to be so like polite and like
customer service he he just flipped a
switch he was like
um and I was just like kindly responding
and I was like listen like we sorry you
didn't respond Airbnb seemed to have
canceled the reservation I would have
waited in the property to like hear back
but we had other plans too so I have no
problem going back as soon as we
finished dinner yes and just like you
know whatever doing the whole exchange
he was like no I can't wait I can't wait
that long you have to be here now you
have to be you have to calm now this is
this is absurd like this is not like
this you this is illegal he said
he's like I'm gonna call the police
Airbnb told me to call the police
because this is illegal so at this point
I'm like why is he like threatening me
now and then he was like saying if you
don't come within the next 15 minutes
because I can't wait until your dinner
ends if you don't come within the next
15 minute minutes I'm throwing all of
your suitcases on the street so I was
like oh my God like what is even
happening all the cops [__] but we're
in like
a foreign country we just Land There we
don't speak French so like even the
thought of calling cops is like a whole
like stressful yeah yeah yeah Endeavor
because it's not easy to do that either
so we're I was just like trying to
resolve the situation I was like okay
okay okay listen
we will be there as soon as we can he's
like no you have to come now if no one's
here now all your [__] is going out on
the street so three of our friends went
back went back they skipped out on
dinner because they're like what the
[__] is even going on like I kind of am
worried about like my things and my
passport that are stuck in the Airbnb so
they went back as we're like some of us
are still at the dinner table
um
and as soon as they get back
they meet with Marcel Marcel's just like
fuming apparently and like waiting out
the door and uh our friend was trying to
get in and he's like oh like let me just
get our stuff and he's like no no no no
you can't go in blocking the door like
with his entire body and he's like you
can't go in this is illegal I'm calling
the police and Nick was like okay Nick
is our friend sorry Nick I just named
dropped you but it's fine yeah it's a
very common name
Nick was like okay like you can feel
free to call the cops like what the [__]
yeah
he's like no give me the keys right now
and then Nick in his mind was just like
okay just no physical altercations and
like don't fight with this guy because
he's like crazy right now and we're in a
different country so yeah so he's like
okay like here's the key can we go get
our stuff now and then this guy just
books it he starts running down the
stairs with the keys and he locks the
door like he just so you stole your [__]
he just basically essentially stole our
[__]
um everything that we own is locked in
his property now we don't have a key we
don't have access we don't have anything
so we're like what the [__] did we do
and they're here they're at the property
dealing with the first hand and I'm at
dinner like not able to enjoy anything
because I'm like talking to Airbnb
trying to get to their like emergency
line they're not helpful at all
um so
I'm at dinner and I'm just like dealing
with this [__] trying to call whoever I
can
um eventually hours later uh one of our
mind you we also have to check in by a
certain time to our next place because
they don't allow like 24-hour check-in
they're like you have to check in within
the next hour or else like you can't
check in so we're like [__] like we have
to be at like four different places at
once like how how are we like supposed
to coordinate all this
um but eventually they call the police
of uh at first they weren't answering
any of the guys calls because they were
speaking English and I guess there were
guys I don't know what the problem was
but they were just like hanging up on
our friends every time they reached out
and then once our one of the girls
called and was like okay this this is
the situation and this Airbnb host is
like basically basically stole our
passports in our luggage and our
belongings then they were like okay
we'll be there yeah so then they we were
like expecting them to show up late but
they surprisingly showed up early really
so they come to the situation they're
just trying to assess it and
um I guess I don't know how it is in
Paris but they were able to like call
the Airbnb host oh wow based off of the
address and the name so
he only lived the host Marcel only lived
like a couple doors down so he was able
to get come immediately but as soon as
they called he came and then he started
acting all innocent and like I had no
idea for what the reason for this to be
angry yeah he was like this is Airbnb
told me to call the police and uh Nick
he he assaulted me he pushed me down the
stairs and uh he called me all these
homophobic slurs and stuff and we're
like hey we didn't even know you were
gay first of all so don't even make that
a thing B nobody touched you nobody
pushed you down any stairs nobody pushed
I would have called his bluff I'd have
been like that's funny because I'm gay
I'm gay as [__] yeah so I was just like
what does this have to do with anything
you can't just like make up all these
things to like he's a [__] sociopath
he's [__] nuts yeah like it was just
so mind-boggling to see that like people
like this actually exist so the police
were starting to like catch on because
like nothing was like adding up in here
and things that he was saying like just
wasn't making sense because he was they
were just like okay you're saying Airbnb
told you to call the police so why are
they calling us yeah and why are we here
with like asking you to take out their
luggage from your property if they're
not even staying here anymore and
they're basically like okay like this
guy's nuts
um he's just mad that he lost the
reservation
again for sure no so okay if that's like
a separate issue but whatever
um so basically I feel like I'm rambling
so much but basically police help us out
they get all of our they force him to
give us our luggage because they're like
this guy is crazy even so I arrived to
the property too after dinner because
I'm like okay like we just gotta go back
and help
um and I'm like talking to one of the
cops and I'm like showing her all of the
receipts and like all the photos and all
the texts and stuff and she's like yeah
okay like he's just crazy she's like I
can't believe you even offered him to
like pay the first night because we were
trying to find a solution to see if that
would make him feel better yeah
um and he was like yeah like I would
like the first night and I was like no
not anymore we offered we offered so she
was like oh oh yeah and then I don't
know what to tell him but yeah so we got
our things back and that was just like a
whole Nightmare and a half to deal with
um but then
did Airbnb like like help you all out
with this [__] after they're like what
the [__] no so Airbnb this is when I got
like so mad because I got a strike on my
account
and for what literally for what there's
no and he had no repercussions from
Airbnb I think Airbnb really protects
her hosts oh [__] that dude yeah so I
was just like what the actual [__] is
going on why am I getting punished for
the illegal actions that he did I did
nothing illegal you Airbnb canceled this
reservation not me yeah I didn't do [__]
you guys canceled it while I was off
site so what am I supposed to do yeah
um
and this guy gets unhinged your host
that you vetted and he's causing us like
all this [__] stress and making us
rebook [__] and like that's we have
extra costs like on orange like ubering
around moving our luggage and like
[__] dealing with the police like it
doesn't make any sense so I was just so
fed up and I was like complaining
Non-Stop and like they also let him
leave a review for me
which like made no sense to me too it's
like I didn't even stay at the place hey
guess what we do in this podcast we're
gonna we're gonna put his [__] Airbnb
tag and everything you [__] piece of
[__] so I eventually like I was just
fighting with them for so long and
someone stepped in and was like I'm so
sorry we do they removed my review on
his account too so I was like what the
[__] no you can't you better leave that
there yeah they're like this this
doesn't follow any of the guidelines and
I'm like it follows every guideline what
are you talking about I do everything by
the book and to the T yeah I'm reading
your guidelines before you even send it
to me so I know that it won't get
deleted yeah so then they're like nope
like it she just kept sending me a link
of the guidelines I'm like dude like
you've read this you sending me the link
over and over again doesn't tell me
anything tell me where my review doesn't
meet the guidelines and she couldn't
answer the question and I like started
sending her all the evidence and all the
photos I was like let me remind you
Airbnb because you're a customer service
agent that like has nothing to do with
anything you're just stepping in yeah
like you don't own the situation but let
me remind you of like everything this
host just did to us so I sent her all
the photos of the police of him the
scene everything in tree I guess like
called her manager or whatever they
stepped in they're like I'm so sorry you
felt invalidated
um we want to make this right so they
like reinstated the review they like
um
that's all they did and then I was like
no I'm not done yeah I'm not done there
yeah I need you to take his review off
of my account because this has nothing
to do with anything
um and I need you to remove the strike
off my account because why am I being
punished yeah for this like it just made
you guys I got [__] yeah that's like
the worst situation ever man like I know
you know like when I talk to customer
service people like I always remind them
like listen
I'm heated and I'm going to express how
upset I am but you're just doing your
job I 100 understand but I gotta say it
how I want to say it so you could relay
that to somebody who can help if I was
in your situation thank God I wasn't I
think I would have [__] beat him into
a [__] stealing from my [__] I think
I would have flipped out I would have
made the situation way worse
have made it bad but I would hospitalize
that fool because like you're stealing
my passport that's like my ticket to get
out of this country we were like our
minds went to like oh my God we need to
go to the Embassy like yes when you're
when you're panicking and you're
thinking of all the worst case scenarios
like I was even like are we gonna have
to camp out in front of the property
because we can't just like leave the
property because when he comes back like
we're gonna have to like make him give
us back the keys and all of our [__]
like we can't just leave all your
passports if we like left the place he
could have just you know gone back in
taking our luggage and like thrown it
out or something I like how he tried to
pull the [__] hate crime card yeah
and also like what was his plan yeah
what were you gonna do I don't know I
just I really don't know but and like I
came over here they called me a
leveragot nobody did that bro stop that
[__] and like the fact that he's still
running his [__] on Airbnb is
Beyond like I mean people are going to
see your post and you put the pictures
and everything else it's going to be
hard for him to book after that because
like I know for me when I see it and I
see pictures like that I'm like
absolutely not yeah she's like nope
don't want to deal with this mess
there's so many other options so more of
a story don't ever book in Paris
specifically because so many people DM
me afterwards telling me their horror
stories and a lot of people had the same
situation as me which is so crazy
because you think that this is like a
one-off thing but no Airbnb more than
two people have had this situation
happen to them this exact situation
happened to them and then like there
were some other stories about like bed
bugs and in Paris and like all this
other [__] so moral of the story stop
don't rent from hotel yeah rent from a
company run property or hotel where like
the owner isn't so [__] personally
invested and like tied up in this [__]
yeah because like so like for me too
like I've had Airbnb situations where we
went to a house and like this house you
could tell the family actually lives in
there yeah and it's like dude a [__]
carpet smells like piss there's like oh
yeah you could use whatever you know
ingredients are in there I'm like you
guys live here yeah [__] it was like I
don't like that even even renting
renting homes like I don't like it when
it's like directly from an owner who
just lived there or it's like their
first property and they like see it as
so precious so they don't want you to
touch anything or do anything it's like
I live here I'm renting from you so I
should be able to do whatever I want so
I I stay away from owners that are too
personally invested 100 and so like when
I went to Paris I had the same situation
but like we were only there for three
[__] days not like in terms of scam
like that but they always take because
it's small it's Metropolitan as [__] so
we go into this uh Airbnb and I'm like
dude this place looks like somebody's
[__] comic book dungeon like what the
[__] is this I'm talking about so small
to the point I could take a [__] wipe my
ass and then wash my hands at the sink
at the same time like I sat there and I
went after I took a [__] I just sat in
the same place I watched my that's how
close the sink was I was shook how small
it was and then me and Mario were just
like well just it's three days like [__]
it we'll just deal with it and then we
talked to a lot of the friends also the
same thing they with the widest angle
ever right I wish I should have known
because I do photos and I'm like I
should have [__] known I looked at
the photos I was like oh he took with
this with like a [__] 16 millimeter
lens so it looks gigantic yeah and I was
just like this is the [__] worst
after that only hotels was it clean at
least
not really wow my biggest thing is the
cleanliness so if it's like more about
the size and like whatever I'll suck it
up but it's the cleanliness is what
bothers bothers me so like in Japan
airbnbs are a lot easier you know it is
what it is it's very honest and very
[__] straightforward which I love but
like in Paris never again it's only
going to be hotels I'll [__] spend
the extra money because I'll have
customer service they all speak English
there it's perfect yeah so it's worth it
I I just can't go through that again
because like traveling in and of itself
is already a lot of anxiety and to have
to deal with that it's [__] insane
one of the things that my mom taught me
was having self-respect is having a nice
accommodation when you're traveling
abroad because it's especially as a
woman like it's all to do with your
safety and the climate like you just
can't
be in these like dangerous situations
whether it's like with the host or the
location or like just dealing with
things yourself like
it's it's you just shouldn't have to do
that in a foreign country where it's
hard it is to like safety is super key
to it like once again if you guys been
to Paris time people who live in Paris
or have lived there can understand like
Paris is not the safest place it really
isn't like it's yeah when we went they
were just like police shootings going on
yeah and [__] like that so I was just
like is it I I don't know if this is a
great time to be in Paris but we're here
that maybe somebody can Enlighten us on
that but like yeah when I went there you
know they had like the whole I think
there was like we drove by this crazy
Refugee encampment like [__] burning
garbage cans of [__] I'm like where the
[__] am I yeah you remind me of like
Detroit I'm like it's Detroit like the
shittiest parts of Detroit like what the
[__] is this so when we imagine Paris we
picture all the most amazing beautiful
which there they are there like I said a
very vast and Lush amount of history and
you know the beautiful parts are very
beautiful right like when you go to
what's that Garden that everybody goes
to at the Palace of Versailles the yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh [__] beautiful
beautiful dude that was my favorite part
of the trip though but that's not even
in Paris it's like just outside of
exactly and there's the other part that
the outdoor Garden that everybody goes
to the other one I can't remember what
it's called oh yeah I have photos of it
but we were there during the time where
it was clear blue skies people were
picnicking or when you go next to like
the canals and people are sitting there
right right beautiful all these
beautiful Parts but the shitty parts are
[__] shitty dude I'll tell you this
too tip if you guys go to the Louvre you
won't be able to see everything it's
impossible I didn't even go inside I
went into the Louvre I was there for
about five hours I saw maybe ten percent
of it yeah it's that [__] big
impossible like and you know getting the
tickets was a whole ordeal there were so
many people inside and it was so vast
like we just had us blast through
everything and when I mean blast through
everything it was only half of it and
then I only saw maybe 10 of it it's that
huge yeah
um definitely the food was
once again it was so hard to find good
food until we had to hit up somebody
yeah because we kept getting [__] yeah
the food we had was pretty bad too yeah
we got [__] so hard and then finally
Mario was like oh I know a couple of
artists at my company that are uh lived
in Paris or and they're actually French
and they told us these places I was like
this is so [__] good but it's not on
any TripAdvisor no Yelp no nothing and
he goes oh this is like pretty popular
and it was popping but how the [__] are
we supposed to know you know yeah the
croissants were pretty [__] amazing
though the bread yeah that's their [__]
I remember like eating the croissant and
I was like the [__] why is it so
different here it's like chewy it's
almost like cheesy like like the way it
pulls and it like I was shook there's
one place out in Pasadena that is very
similar to that so oh really it's a
place called car artisanal chocolates
and so they were uh on they were like
number one on eater for a place to get
croissants and I've been going there for
a while now because my buddy Nick his
friend opened it up and he did uh he's a
chocolatier so he did a chocolate thing
in this other small coffee shop till he
opened up his place in Pasadena and uh
he is a Madman when it comes to
croissants and it's the only croissant
that I've ever had in the states that
tastes like the croissants in Paris in
France and they blew up I'm talking
about when I went there it was like a
small spot they had a couch and there
was a you know it was pretty busy you
know good business that article comes
out I get there from they opened up at
11 to 1 they sold all the croissants out
and it was a line out the [__] door
it was like that for like two months I
was pissed I couldn't get a [__]
croissant which is like the most [__]
uh virtual problem ever yeah you know
but if you guys ever want a dope
croissant in La
um go to go to car out in Pasadena
you'll [__] love it it's delicious
almond croissants chocolate croissants
whatever you want on a positive note the
people that I encountered in Paris like
servers Uber drivers they were all so
nice yeah the people are about one the
the one Uber driver that picked us up
from the airport was like you guys don't
speak French big problem big problem
we're like oh but everybody was like
kind of offended but I was like this is
Paris yeah I'm getting the treatment
yeah but then everybody asked her yeah
but everybody after him was just they
were so nice yeah we only ran into one
person that was a [__] dick but it
wasn't as bad as people said it they
said it was but I heard it's kind of
like how people talk about Korean food
back in the day I heard back in the day
it was very much like that but now
they're a lot more Global tourism
there's a lot more is coming in a lot so
everybody's just a lot nicer than they
used to be but I heard like 10 years ago
it was very much like that you're
American they're like stupid Americans
the [__] are you doing here but we ran
to one guy at a Fruit Stand where we
were just trying to get some fruits and
he was a [__] [__] dude he was like
yelling at us mad at us that we don't
speak [__] French that we don't know
what we're doing and then somebody had
to step in and [__] curse them out
for us like what the [__] are you
yelling at these people for I'm just
like I just want an orange dog you know
I just want a [__] orange
you know but this guy was [__] mad at
us Mario did this one thing that cracked
me up in France there was this older
person who was a server and we went to
the same spot in the morning so we can
get a
um like a cappuccino
and uh a croissant and some eggs or
whatever whatnot like the breakfast
culture isn't like Americans right it's
usually like a pastry and a coffee and
you're out
or espresso shot so we get espresso and
this is the only place that was doing
breakfast which was like very simple
[__] French omelette and like a
croissant so Muriel gets her [__]
scrambled eggs and she goes do you have
any ketchup and the French waiter funny
guy looks at Amigo
catch up screamed it out loud his Bear's
like what the [__] and he gets his uh he
gets his uh [__] uh menu and then she
has a hat on he starts tapping her head
like this
yeah he was super [__] dope and then
he was serving us every day that we got
breakfast there he was [__] nice man
so Paris does have a lot of like really
cool things but you have to know what to
look for and honestly like look for
other travel people who either live
there that'll show you what's up because
you're just not going to know but I
definitely like the art and the culture
there I love the fact yeah it's all
about art and culture it has it has
[__] Beauty man if you don't
appreciate those types of things
to think oh a hundred percent like I
wanted to go to like the south of France
too we didn't just have a we didn't have
enough time and then her friend was
showing us pictures of stuff that we
could do there I was like I want to go
too it's like [__] yeah we should have
went there but we were there for a
wedding at the time it was uh Tiffany
and Casey's wedding and so we were just
there in France for that moment and then
we had to leave after but I I definitely
like Europe is a place that I really
want to go travel again to because I
definitely go to Asia a lot yeah I think
I like Asian food I like I honestly feel
like I prefer to be
in like South America or Asia that's
more my vibe I like Asia a lot South
America scares me
there's nothing that scares the [__]
[__] out well I say this it's such a
generalized statement I've only been to
Peru
like I definitely there's like I want to
go to like Colombia or whatever whatnot
but I have friends who are like
Colombian and they're like stay away you
know if you go you got to go with
somebody who knows like yeah you could
be fine but when things go bad things go
really bad so you know just be very
mindful of that and it happens to a lot
of like tours there's a lot of girls
trips like they go out there and they're
like what the [__] are you doing and
it's like the worst time of their life
they're getting sexually harassed
there's like other [__] that's going on
there
um so I'm very wary of those countries
unless I'm prepped for it perfectly
right but I know that now if you go to
like places like Cambodia and Vietnam
because they're becoming a lot more
industrialized and becoming more tourist
friendly as long as you stay in the
tourist areas it's a lot easier to
travel around and you're not going to be
as bad for me if I go to Vietnam
apparently I'm a giant like you probably
yeah like you go there just know that
you're gonna stick out really bad like
you're on like everybody there's like
115 pounds they're gonna be like whoa do
you think I'm a basketball player to
take photos with me and even Japan now
like people are a little taller than
they used to be so it's not as bad but I
went there for the first time like seven
years ago I I stuck out pretty hard like
I remember the even the subway rail
handles were like here because I was so
[__] tall but now it's like a little
higher when you went to Korea did you
notice everybody was really tall really
tall everyone's so tall I was like the
average height yeah I was kind of like
shook even the girls are like at least
five seven average my relative told me
out there it's like they're all tall but
some of the a lot of them are cheating
because they were the eels
so when everybody was like six feet tall
he was like they're probably like more
like five eight five nine I'm like okay
that makes more sense yeah I was shook
they're like yeah if you wore the the
heel thing you'd be like six three six
four I'm like yeah I'm not doing that
that was the point of that like I am the
height that I am but they're very well
put together I thought I was like damn
y'all everybody got BB cream on your
hook like y'all's kids are [__]
Flawless and [__] every guy Wears Like
purses or like nurses yeah yeah yeah
they definitely got that [__]
you know what the crazy thing is like
secret society has uh like this
crossback right and I remember when I
was like
in high school you would never catch me
dead with this [__] yeah yeah I would
get my ass beat definitely not that's
different times different times right
but now two was like look you got a cell
phone that's the size of a tablet you
got the keys the wallet how the [__] are
you gonna carry this in your pants yeah
you can't impossible even the baggiest
past how the [__] are you gonna carry
this it's not possible now I have a bag
with me at all times because it's just
pointless to carry in my pockets and
it's uncomfortable and it makes your
clothes look black yeah so like after
that now I always have a bag on me at
all times it's like you need to
chapstick maybe I got you yeah why this
is literally what girls carry bags for
it makes [__] sense I got my
headphones
I got my wallet eventually you keep
sizing up and finding more things to put
in your bag
it's like what else can I fit in here
I'm Audrey
I feel like if I don't have this with me
it's just my pants are weighing me down
yeah and I absolutely hate it even now
like when I have like this uh phone in
my pocket I'm like damn it's kind of
comfortable yeah I'm saying yeah if you
could give somebody like three three top
tips when they travel what would it be
oh
definitely plan ahead and make
reservations but be okay with things not
going according to your plan so like it
just
you can't be so rigid in your schedule
like even create time blocks for things
to go wrong I would say number one
number two number two
stop relying on [__] Google reviews
and Yelp yeah like just walk into places
try it just like Google there's so many
places that I went to even my most
recent trip to Europe that were like
four point eight four point nine
terrible crash all so bad and I wish I
would have just like walked around and
like like looked for myself
um three
don't [__] book airbnbs in Paris
that was the thing too like that was our
biggest tip that we told people when
they go to Japan it's like you know
bloggers when they do blogging stuff
they're looking at other people's blogs
so you're not gonna really [__] know
like if you look at a spot and the food
looks amazing and there's a few people
in there give it a go yeah what what the
[__] gonna happen I just try it out
and the best food that we had in Japan
were the places that we didn't plan out
and I'm like okay I [__] up and there
are spots like in Japan that you'll see
like people in Japan they review it
looks amazing but for me when I travel
I'm not waiting in line yeah I'm sorry I
hate that I'm not doing three hours in
line I have a limited time here so there
was like this place in Japan that has
like this pile of seafood with the
equator like the rice and stuff and it's
popping right now that wait in line was
like two hours and I'm like
I'm not doing that we found another
place that was very similar and it was
fire yeah I'm like I don't need to go
there so I could do the video reel
nothing is worth like hours in line
nothing to me is worth waiting hours in
line for time is precious dude so if I
can get a similar experience somewhere
else where there's nobody there I'm
gonna code there dude so like Japan too
that was I think that's a really good
tip it's like don't be afraid to explore
outside of the things that you already
said planned yeah because you're gonna
find some of the the best things and the
best experiences that you have when it's
on the Fly and that's what traveling's
for like you're supposed to be
uncomfortable a little bit and
experience new things and I think that I
kind of like going to places where I am
a little uncomfortable where I can't
speak the language because it just
forces me to try new things like just
doing like the Google translate thing
everything you do that you don't think
about in America or like wherever your
home country is you have to think like
five times about in a foreign country
like you second guess yourself with
every decision and everything you do and
that's why I like it because it makes
you very intentional about everything
that you're doing yeah we we sometimes
take for granted the
how awesome the places that we live in
are because we just live in it so like I
like I'm trying my best to kind of
change my lens to somebody who comes and
visits LA because they have a list of
[__] I'm like what the [__] is that
for Real's like you've definitely done
this I'm like yeah I did no I did I'm
like hey can I come and they have a
different lens because they're looking
at this place like it's fresh and new
yeah and then I have a better time in
this city when people come here yeah I
think it's so important to be a tourist
in your own City too it's all about
perspective yeah seriously because I
even me being in La I'm kind of like I'm
kind of bored like there's nothing to do
here anymore but then I was like wait
but I used to visit all the freaking
time and it was so fun every time I
visited like what was different and it
was just the perspective it's like you
just gotta look at things as if like
I don't know you just you got to be
grateful for the things around you I
think when you take it for granted then
it's just like oh it's like yeah there's
a reason why people [__] come and
visit here yeah right and how come they
they find out they have all these cool
pictures that's why when we were in New
York on the rooftop bar I was like look
at this view people I'll travel the
world I can't believe I get to live here
I wanted to throw her off the balcony
it's true it was just such a TV moment
that I saw in real life I was like am I
on an episode of Dawson's Creek what's
going on here yeah I was like I I
understood though I have to make fun of
you though but I get it it was very
beautiful like the site the the the
cityscape and everything I was like this
is beautiful but you didn't have to say
that out loud
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast I'll help you
go out there you travel hopefully you
don't experience the [__] [__] that
she went through that is a disaster I
would have lit that man on fire dude and
I would have [__] in his mouth but uh
you could catch freesia freesia Park
your your YouTube name is Frasier part
two right just straight up first and
last name uh check out her videos
lifestyle videos cool stuff fashion food
whatever you could think of she does it
really aesthetic very nice very
beautiful check it out on Instagram as
well genius friend every Sundays at 12pm
and we'll see you all next time peace